fifty thousand years ago
Neanderthals roamed Europe in West Asia
the strong big-bodied species had ruled
these parts for more than 150 thousand
years they made tools such as flint hand
axes and they hunted mammoths and other
large animals then the game changed
Neanderthal territory shrank and
populations with more sophisticated
tools appeared these new players may
have been Neanderthals who developed new
skills or the first modern looking
humans to reach Europe or a mixture of
the two
soon after the appearance of these
mysterious Tech's a V groups the
Neanderthals disappeared completely and
Homo sapiens ruled Europe our species
won the game that's roughly what
happened scientists want to learn more
about how this game of survival and
extinction played out when exactly did
the Neanderthals disappear and how much
do they overlap with modern looking
humans providing opportunities for the
two species to share ideas and have sex
it's difficult to accurately date human
remains and artifacts but recently
improvements in radiocarbon dating have
produced more reliable dates for these
events let's replay the Neanderthal
survival game with help from Tom hayamin
team from the University of Oxford they
dated remains from more than 40 sites
across Europe they showed that the
Neanderthals weren't wiped out suddenly
instead beginning around 45,000 years
ago their territory grew smaller but
Neanderthals still lived in pockets of
southern Europe around the same time the
new players entered the game they
produced a greater range of tools
including more sophisticated stone
blades and pointed bone all's possibly
used to make clothes they also carved
ivory pendants and used ochre and other
pigments this kind of symbolic behavior
is the basis for language art and even
religion an archaeologists debate
whether Neanderthals possessed these
abilities its paws
people that modern-looking humans moved
into southern Europe bringing their
tools and artwork with them and then
some Neanderthals simply copied these
technologies alternatively Neanderthals
may have created these objects on their
own pointing to a capacity for symbolic
thought the new study shows that these
two transitional cultures as they're
called coexisted making the copying
theory more likely the team says as the
game continued more Neanderthal
populations disappeared
some scientists have proposed that the
last Neanderthal stronghold was in
iberia but the team found no convincing
evidence of this their data suggests
that Neanderthals survived in several
parts of Europe and overlapped with
modern looking humans for several
thousand years ample time for exchange
of ideas and plenty of opportunities for
interbreeding but by thirty-five
thousand years ago all traces of the
Neanderthals were gone and our species
dominated the continent scientists still
debate why Neanderthals lost in humans
one climate change and increased
competition for food and land probably
played important roles but like any game
the outcome may have also come down to
chance
maybe next time humans won't be so lucky
you